♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOR THE LAST YEAR
WE'VE TOLD YOU WAS GOING ON IN
AMERICAN SCHOOLS.
FROM KINDERGARTEN ALL THE WAY
INTO GRADUATE SCHOOL, AT EVERY
SINGLE LEVEL, EQUITY HAS CHANGED
THE WAY KIDS ARE TAUGHT AND IT'S
CHANGED VERY MUCH WHAT THEY ARE
TAUGHT AND ITS POISONING THEM.
VERY FEW PARENTS HAVE FOUGHT
BACK, BUT SOME ARE BEGINNING TO.
HERE'S ONE IN FLORIDA, A MOTHER
CALLED KEISHA KING TOLD HER
SCHOOL BOARD WHAT THIS KIND OF
INDOCTRINATION.
>> IT'S THAT WE ARE EVEN
CONTEMPLATING SOMETHING LIKE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY WHERE THEY
WILL BE DEFINED THE OPPRESSORS
OR OPPRESSED.
THAT IS NOT TEACHING THE TRUTH
UNLESS YOU BELIEVE THAT WHITES
ARE BETTER THAN BLACKS.
TELLING MY CHILD OR ANY CHILD
THAT THEY ARE IN A PERMANENT
OPPRESSED STATUS IN AMERICA
BECAUSE THEY ARE BLACK IS A
RACIST.
IF THIS CONTINUES, WE WILL LOOK
BACK AND BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DISMANTLING OF THE GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD BY
REVERTING TO TEACHING HATE AND
THAT THE RACE IS A DETERMINING
FACTOR OF WHERE.
>> Tucker: GOOD FOR HER, SHE'S
TELLING THE TRUTH.
TOO IF YOU ARE.
THE 1776 GROUP -- A PROJECT,
DESIGNED TO HELP SCHOOL BOARDS,
COMMUNITIES ELECT SANE PEOPLE TO
RUN THEIR SCHOOLS.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE THEM ON
NOW.
>> SO THE 1776 PROJECT PACK IS A
SUPER PAC THAT ANYONE CAN DONATE
TO FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF THIS YEAR
AND HOPEFULLY NEXT YEAR, WE WILL
BE DONATING AND CAMPAIGNING ON
BEHALF OF SCHOOL BOARD
CANDIDATES WHO OPPOSE CRITICAL
RACE THEORY BEING TAUGHT IN
SCHOOLS AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO
USE THEIR POSITION AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER TO BUY TEXTBOOKS
THAT ARE PATRIOTIC AND TELL A
REASONABLE AND REALISTIC HISTORY
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO PUSH FOR
SUPERINTENDENTS THAT TEACHERS
WHO ARE ACTIVISTS, WORK TO MAKE
EDUCATION SANE AGAIN FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: IT'S FUNNY, SO YOU
ARE BASICALLY COUNTERBALANCING
OR TRYING TO WHAT GEORGE SOROS
HAS BEEN DOING FOR 30 YEARS,
INFLUENCING LOCAL ELECTIONS.
AND SOMEONE IS FINALLY DOING IT
BACK.
ARE YOU GETTING A GOOD RESPONSE?
>> I STARTED TWO WEEKS AGO, OVER
700 PEOPLE HAVE DONATED.
IF GONE THOUSANDS OF EMAILS FROM
CANADA AND PARENTS WHO HAVE
SAID, THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN MY SCHOOL AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO, I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
FIGHT BACK.
HOW DO I FIND THAT, WHAT'S BEEN
ACTIVE IN MY SCHOOL?
THIS DIALOGUE IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
THEY DON'T WANT THIS RADICAL
APPROACH TO EDUCATION BEING
PUSHED.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS RACISM,
THERE'S NO OTHER WORD FOR IT.
YET MANY, MANY DIFFERENT VARIETY
OF CHILDREN'S FOR MANY DIFFERENT
REASONS -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE DOING
THIS.
THERE ARE ELECTIONS ALREADY
BEING HELD.
WE'VE SEEN ANTI-CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
AND I HOPE THAT I CAN DO MY
PART.
THESE ARE NOT A VERY EXPENSIVE
ELECTIONS TO RUN, THEY ARE
NONPARTISAN MOST OF THE TIME.
I THINK WE CAN REALLY GO FAR AND
DO A LOT WITH VERY LITTLE.
AND YOU KNOW, IT'S AMAZING THAT
WITH ALL THE MONEY IN
CONSERVATIVE INC. AND
CONSERVATIVE GROUPS THAT IT TOOK
A KID FROM QUEENS TO DO THIS.
I'M REALLY PROUD AND I HOPE WE
CHANGE THE WAY EDUCATION IS
BEING DONE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, MOST PEOPLE
HATE THE STUFF.
BUT MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE THE
BOWL EITHER.
IF YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
WRITING A CHECK, MAYBE Y